- [Instructor] When we're
talking about waves,
transmission is when a
wave passes from a material
into another one.
For example, here we have the sun,
93 million miles away on average,
and imagine the different materials
that the light has to
travel through from the sun
to, say, hit one of these sand
particles right over here.
Think about what it needs
to be transmitted through.
What's going to travel
through 93 million miles
of the vacuum of space,
and that's one of the amazing
things about light waves
is that they don't need a medium.
They can travel through
vacuum, through emptiness,
but then it's gonna travel
through several miles
of Earth's atmosphere.
So it's going to travel
through several miles
of Earth's atmosphere.
It will hit these, the
lenses of these sunglasses,
the light will travel through
the lenses of the sunglass,
little sunglass has some
width or some depth to it,
and then it'll go out onto the other side
and it will hit the sand right over here.
Now, one thing you might realize
is the amount of transmission
and what gets transmitted
is dependent on the
wavelengths of the wave,
in this case, the wavelengths of light,
and also about the material
that they are going through.
So for example, these
sunglasses right over here,
many sunglasses try to keep out
UV light, ultraviolet light,
which is a higher frequency
than visible light,
but that's what causes sunburns
and that can also damage your eyes.
So those high frequencies
are not making it through.
And we can also see that this
sunglass right over here,
it kind of has an orange color,
which means that things that are closer
to that end of the spectrum,
closer to the red, the
oranges, and the yellows
are getting through,
which means that it's
filtering out blue light.
So the blue light, isn't getting
transmitted through as much
as say the red, orange, and yellow light
and that's why we see this
as red, orange, or yellow.
And then, of course,
the light will get to that sand particle.
Now transmission, as I mentioned,
it isn't just about light waves.
We could talk about
one of our other favorite types of waves,
for example, sound waves.
If you are in a room,
you have probably experienced the fact
that even if you were to close the door,
and I do this a lot because
I record a lot of videos.
This is me in my little
closet recording a video.
This is a top view for
what I'm doing right now.
A lot of times my kids are
in other parts of the house
and they're making a lot of noise.
And as we've talked about,
sound waves are nothing but
traveling pressure waves
through the air.
Those air particles are
knocking one into another.
But in order to make it to me,
they need to get through that wall,
and the way they do that
is they get transmitted through that wall.
So those air particles make the particles
or make the atoms or the molecules
in the walls start vibrating,
they bump into each other,
and then the particles on
the other side of the wall
will bump into the air
in my little closet,
and then we will have, once again,
the sound waves make it to me.
Now, the overall magnitude of sound,
the volume of the sound,
will likely be diminished
and not all of the
frequencies of the sound
will be transmitted equally.
Different frequencies of sound waves
are better at traveling
through certain materials,
just as we talked about with light waves.
So now when you look at
the world around you,
or you hear the world around you,
or look at other types of waves,
just think about how it's transmitting
from one material into another.